Let us now give an example of a
continuous random variable--
the uniform random variable.
It is patterned after the
discrete random variable.
Similar to the discrete case,
we will have a range of
possible values.
In the discrete case, these
values would be the integers
between a and b.
In the continuous case, any real
number between a and b
will be possible.
In the discrete case, these
values were equally likely.
In the continuous case, at all
points, we have the same
height for the probability
density function.
And as a consequence, if we take
two intervals that have
the same length, then these two
intervals will be assigned
the same probability.
Intuitively, uniform random
variables model
the following situation.
We know that the numerical value
of the random variable
will be between a and b.
But we know nothing more.
We have no reason to believe
that certain locations are
more likely than others.
And in this sense, the uniform
random variable models a
situation of complete
ignorance.
By the way, since probabilities
must add to 1,
the area of this rectangle
must be equal to 1.
And therefore, the height of
this rectangle has to be 1
over b minus a, so that
we have a height of 1
over b minus a.
We have a length of b minus a.
So the product of the
two, which is the
area, is equal to 1.
Finally, here's a more
general PDF, which
is piecewise constant.
One thing to notice is that
this, in particular, tells us
that PDFs do not have to be
continuous functions.
They can have discontinuities.
Of course, for this to be a
legitimate PDF, the total area
under the curve, which is the
sum of the areas of the
rectangles that we have here,
must be equal to 1.
With a piecewise constant PDF,
we can calculate probabilities
of events fairly easy.
For example, if you wish to find
the probability of this
particular interval, which is
going to be the area under the
curve, that area really consists
of two pieces.
We find the areas of these two
rectangles, add them up, and
this gives us the total
probability of
this particular interval.
So at this point, our
agenda, moving
forward, will be twofold.
First, we will introduce
some interesting
continuous random variables.
We just started with the
presentation of the uniform
random variable.
And then, we will also go over
all of the concepts and
results that we have developed
for discrete random variables
and develop them again for their
continuous counterparts.